scuffles at the event honoring sarah
everard police had tried to cancel it
because of lockdown rules
the home secretary says the scenes have
been upsetting and she's demanding a
full report
the mayor of london says what the
officers did has been unacceptable that
imbaba reports
they've been warned not to come but they
were defiant this crowd
women and men rallied in south london
near where marketing executive sarah
everard went missing
a serving police officer has now been
charged with her abduction and murder
i'm hurting
for her and for every other woman and
myself is so wrong
you know it's it's not fair for anyone
for any one of us
and it's not about hating people and
hating
the government is about making changes
sarah was last seen walking from a
friend's apartment in clapham to her
home elsewhere in south london
a week after she disappeared sarah's
body was found in woodland in kent more
than 80 kilometers away
the case has sparked a social media
avalanche of testimony
many women detailing how they've spent
their whole lives being subjected to
abuse
and having to be on guard since sarah
everard's disappearance women from all
walks of life have come
forward with their own accounts of how
they've been harassed
followed assaulted raped and many of
them are saying that it's men that need
to change their attitudes
because every single woman knows the
feeling of being frightened
whose responsibility is it it's
everyone's responsibility
the problem is that women have
shouldered most of that burden
up until now and now men need to step
up every single man needs to be a role
model to our boys
they need to be a conscience don't know
to their friends
to their colleagues to their brothers
and most of all they need to be an ally
to women
a recent study commissioned by campaign
group un women uk
reflects the disturbing reality over 70
percent of women of all ages had
experienced some form of sexual
harassment in public places
the figures were highest for the
youngest respondents with 97 percent of
18 to 24 year olds
experiencing sexual harassment in public
and despite all that many women didn't
think it was worth reporting incidents
over 95 of our respondents said that
across the spectrum of incidents that
they'd experienced
they had not um reported all of the
incidents that
they'd been through and that had
happened to them so very few people
are reporting um and that includes a
spectrum of behaviors from what you
might describe as milder
sexual harassment such as cat calling
and wolf whistling
but also more serious assault groping
being followed or coerced into sexual
activity without consent
saturday's series of nationwide vigils
was cancelled after london police said
this event
couldn't go ahead because of covid19
guidelines
in some places people mark the event on
their doorsteps instead
but they all sent the same message
asking those in power to take their
abuse seriously
and asking men to challenge each other
nadeem baba al-jazeera
london